es ist der seltsamste stern dem
universum beobachtet haben kec 8 28 52
verdunkelt sich so stark und so
unregelmäßig dass ein exo planeten
nicht dafür verantwortlich sein kann
astronomen vermuten deshalb locker
liehen mega strukturen also bauwerke die
so riesig sind dass sie in der lage
wären ganze sterne zu verdanken
jetzt gibt es eine weitere erklärung
die zum seitenwechsel herbst willkommen
wir vermuten hier darüber berichtet
beim stern ki ka 4 6 2 852 gibt es nicht
mit rechten dingen zu 70 trilliarden
sterne gibt es so ungefähr im universum
150000 davon beobachtet das
weltraumteleskop kepler auf der suche
nach exoplaneten damit auf der suche
nach einer möglichen heimat von
außerirdischen ein stern nicht dabei
heraus weil es nicht nur seltsam
verhält wie kein anders gestellt wie
846 2852 babys sterben benannt wurde er
nach der astronomen die ihn zum ersten
mal näher beschrieb und seine
helligkeitsschwankungen untersuchte
gabetta wo ja ja aber auch sie habe
keine erklärung für sein verhalten ein
exoplanet konnte es nicht sein
die schwankungen sind zu unregelmäßig
und zu stark ein cometen schwarm würde
sich so nicht verhalten ein junger stern
dennoch entsteht der bisher hat keine
merkmale eines der zwei planeten stoßen
vor dem stern zusammen
der staub fällt deshalb stellt
astrophysiker jason wright von der penn
state university die these auf dass dort
eine alien zivilisation für die
verdunklung verantwortlich ist seine
idee alien mega strukturen wie zum
beispiel eine riesige tysons wäre eine
hülle um den stern auf dessen
innenseite aliens leben doch dafür
fehlen zwei vermutete eigenschaften von
teppich stern gebe es eine mega struktur
mit sonnenkollektoren oder solarzellen
wird ein infrarot überschuss das von
ihm ausgesendeten lichts erwartet den
gibt es nicht und wti die search for
extraterrestrial intelligence also die
suche nach außerirdischer intelligenz
hat seine radioteleskope auf den stern
ausgerichtet und nichts gefunden wird
keine gnade
da beta pro jahr verlangt für eine
solche these irgendwelche indizien
irgendwelche beweise zitat
außergewöhnliche behauptungen
verlangen nach außergewöhnlichen
belegen
ja aber das ist im moment noch einsatz
mit xf geht nichts außer dem
unregelmäßigen flackern aber auch im
gegenzug heißt das nicht denn auch für
alle bisherigen ideen gibt es keine
belege und vielleicht sind die
außerirdischen durchaus so schlau
ansonsten keine beweise für ihre
distanz ins weltall zu schicken das
thema hat mir schon mal im mai selbst
einen neuen abfall der leuchtkraft des
sterns der jetzt mit mehreren teleskopen
parallel beobachten würde darüber
hatten wir berichtet und jetzt gibt es
bereits die erste arbeit die auf den
daten dieser beobachtung bewertung das
ergebnis ist ja sagen wir mal komplex
der spanische astronomen fernando
ballesteros muss die letzten wochen tag
und nacht durchgearbeitet haben um seine
arbeit so schnell fertig bekommen zu
haben seine theorie es ist simpel und
einfach nicht ein objekt sondern es ist
eine komplexe anordnung von mehreren
objekten league am g 8 46 28 52 vorbei
ziehen erstens ist es ein exoplanet
zweitens hat der wieder saturn große
allerdings stark licht schlucken geringe
die sich um in bremen briten kreist ein
dichter aktuellen schwarm um tabus stern
und viertens noch ein wichter aktiven
schwamm um den stern
das ist aber viel auf einmal aber diese
theorie ist wenigstens überprüfbar bei
der theorie sagt nämlich auch die
nächste verdunklung voraus demnach wird
ein asteroiden schwamm anfang 2021
wieder den stand verdunkeln und in der
ersten jahre feste 2023 wird wieder der
ring planet daran vorbei ziehen so seine
vermutung facto nicht ein
ja das sind wir wieder am anfang oder
gibt es vorher indizien oder beweise
für die medien mega struktur müssen
wir in diese richtung weiter forschen
auf jeden fall bleibt es spannend wie
immer erfahrt ihr hier
die aktuelle entwicklung dürfte dafür
einfach hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesslich den auf die glocke ja und
hier geht es weiter mit einem weiteren
video über kiz 86 2 852 alien mega
struktur wieder aktiv da erklärt eine
solche struktur näher einfach
draufklicken meldet euch interessiert
und ansonsten bis dann gleich machen